[Musique]
LCP Assemblée Nationale en partenariat
avec MGEN mutuelle santé prévoyance
présente état de santé
[Musique]
TDAH pour certains c'est une étiquette
bien commode un problème d'éducation ou
une simple mode pourtant le trouble
déficit de l'attention avec ou sans
hyperactivité est une réalité pour de
nombreuses familles ils touchent environ
5% des enfants d'âge scolaires et
devrait pouvoir être diagnostiqué jeune
se trouve si je l'avais su beaucoup plus
tôt j'aurais pu réussir ma scolarité
j'aurais pu ne pas souffrir autant
j'aurais pu ne pas faire souffrir non
plus mais mon entourage au delà du TDAH
dans les classes la concentration est
devenue un défi majeur on est sans cesse
en train de dire taisez-vous attention
calmez-vous
face à l'essor des sources de
distraction faut-il craindre une
épidémie de ces troubles de la tension
comment mieux les comprendre TDAH
au-delà des idées reçues c'est le thème
de ce nouveau numéro d'état de santé
[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro des tas de santé aujourd'hui on
va s'intéresser à une maladie dont on
connaît le nom depuis assez récemment
très longtemps pendant des décennies les
parents ont été laissés sans réponse
finalement face aux défauts
de concentration de leur enfant et puis
il y a quoi il y a une vingtaine
trentaine d'années on a mis un nom le
nom c'est TDAH trouble de l'attention
avec ou sans hyperactivité les solutions
on va en parler avec notre invité
bonjour à vous Charlotte van derdriguez
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
vous êtes psychiatre spécialiste du TDAH
j'ai dit TDAH c'est trouble de
l'attention avec ou sans hyperactivité
vous le diriez comment avec vos mots un
trouble qui allie à la fois un déficit
de l'attention qui est toujours présent
et plus ou moins d'hyperactivité suivant
suivant la personnalité aussi de
l'enfant ça c'est très important je
rebondis tout de suite là dessus parce
que souvent quand on entend TDAH quand
on s'évaguement on pense à
l'hyperactivité vous nous dites que
l'hyperactivité ça n'est pas forcément
le symptôme du TDAH au fur et à mesure
que la description du trouble
a avancer on s'est rendu compte que en
fait le problème de l'attention était en
fait bien plus important et toujours
présent avec une impulsivité qui peut
être donc mental c'est impossibilité de
maintenir son cours de la pensée comme
ça mais qui peut être motrice garçon
fille il y a quatre fois plus de petits
garçons
diagnostiqués que de petites filles le
ratio est actuellement comme ça dans le
dans le diagnostic mais on pense que les
petites filles sont largement sous
diagnostiqués car moins hyperactive donc
finalement elle passerait inaperçue du
coup c'est une idée reçue qu'on a il y a
beaucoup plus peut-être de TDAH qu'on
croit parce que on repère pas
l'hyperactivité n'existe pas
on est on est avec ce trouble tout à
fait c'est de naissance alors
l'héritabilité est estimée autour de 75%
dans héritabilité il faut voir la partie
génétique des gènes qu'on hérite de ses
parents mais aussi les habitudes souvent
quand on diagnostique un enfant un des
deux parents on va dire au psychiatre ah
mais en fait moi aussi on va y revenir
sur tout ça mais d'abord votre portrait
[Musique]
Charlotte van dendrich est psychiatre et
chercheuse en sciences cognitives après
avoir exercé à l'hôpital Robert Debré à
Paris cette spécialiste du TDAH termine
aujourd'hui sa thèse au Laboratoire de
sciences cognitives et psychologue de
l'École normale supérieure son objectif
étudier le fonctionnement du cerveau des
personnes présentant de faibles
capacités d'attention et montrer
qu'au-delà du déficit le TDAH peut être
perçu comme un avantage dans certains
contextes en termes de curiosité par
exemple
[Musique]
alors dans ce portrait ce qu'on n'a pas
dit c'est que vous-même vous avez été
diagnostiqué TDAH ça a été longue
diagnostic non alors c'était très ça a
été très tardif et puis c'est plutôt moi
au cours de mes études de médecine lors
d'un stage en psychiatrie mais oui vous
êtes dit ben tiens finalement
un recoupement de difficultés de
maintenir son attention le problème de
sommeil aussi mais qui au final n'ont
pas eu beaucoup de retentissement dans
dans ma scolarité mais il vous a sans
doute porté à vous y intéresser
particulièrement vous disiez tout à
l'heure c'est héréditaire ça n'est pas
que héréditaire la réalité c'est quoi
c'est que c'est l'interaction entre les
deux il y a une hérédité on hérite d'un
profil comportemental attentionnel de
ses parents et on va rencontrer un
environnement stressant
le résultat va être que les symptômes
vont augmenter et le révélateur donc
c'est l'école parce que c'est là où les
conséquences sont les plus importantes
de ce défaut d'attention c'est ça
souvent la classe un peu fatidique c'est
le CP ou on demande aux enfants de
rester assis donc voilà quelquefois les
enfants qui sont pas particulièrement
hyperactifs ont finalement du mal à en
maternelle ont finalement du mal à
rester assis alors gigote sur leur
chaise et tout ça et ont beaucoup
beaucoup de difficultés à maintenir leur
attention sur ce que la maîtresse va
dire ou sur le travail qui doit faire
tout seul donc vraiment souvent c'est
l'âge de diagnostic le plus fabriquant
c'est six sept ans c'est quand même
assez assez jeune parce que très vite de
repérage de repérage conséquences donc
sur le parcours scolaire d'autant plus
que les autres troubles des
apprentissages sont souvent associés
dans 70% des cas on retrouve d'autres
troubles des apprentissages comment on
diagnostique quels sont les outils c'est
un diagnostic qui est clinique
uniquement c'est à dire que sur des
entretiens et des observations de
l'enfant donc on a des questionsnaires
standardisés qui permettent d'objectiver
un peu pour les pour les parents mais
c'est vraiment uniquement clinique on
n'a pas de mesure par aclinique
et les parents qui arrivent en demandant
un diagnostic ils sont épuisés parce
qu'ils ont cru souvent on est encore à
une époque où on croit que bon c'est
juste un problème de caractère et que
c'est pas un trouble en tant que tel les
parents sont épuisés ils culpabilisent
énormément de plus en plus
la communication qui est faite sur le
TDAH aide les parents parce que du coup
ils peuvent aussi
identifier les comportements repérés et
tout ça mais c'est pour ça que c'est
important qu'on en parle aujourd'hui
parce que plus ce sera diffusé plus les
parents sont en capacité de se dire
peut-être pas de ma faute ou c'est
peut-être pas simplement une question de
caractère justement Marianne Cazot
pourrait être santé est allé rencontrer
des patients pour comprendre évidemment
comment à quel moment le diagnostic a pu
se faire et ce qu'il a évidemment changé
on regarde leur portage de mariage
[Musique]
parfois quelques mots seulement peuvent
avoir beaucoup d'impact dans la famille
de Marie cette mots suffit
difficile de l'attention avec
hyperactivité DH car ce diagnostic posé
sur les difficultés de Milo 8 ans a été
une grande source de soulagement après
plusieurs années de question rester sans
réponse on est dans le flou on sait pas
où on va on sait pas vers qui se tourner
pour avoir de l'aide donc c'est vrai que
en tant que parents c'est un peu on sent
démunie en fait et là d'avoir ce
diagnostic et de savoir vers quelle
professionnelle on peut se tourner ou
que de la guidance parentale de choses
comme ça ça peut aider ben oui c'est un
soutien
pour Milo aussi les choses ont évolué
désormais ils ne rentrent plus de
l'école fatiguée et angoissée à l'idée
d'y retourner
à l'école
tu pleurais je devais te tirer par la
main pour aller à l'école
tu t'en souviens
parce que je pense que tu étais pas très
bien en classe
c'était difficile pour toi
cette année c'est un petit peu mieux
qu'est-ce qui fait que c'est mieux
qu'est-ce qu'a changé cette année
[Musique]
et pour lui ce n'est pas anodin à
l'école comme à l'heure des devoirs il
ne peut se concentrer sans remuer
en classe Milo utilise ce coussin qui
lui permet de bouger tout en restant
assis et dans son agenda le maître
apporte désormais des corrections
des aménagements que Marie a pu obtenir
grâce au diagnostic posé dès les 7 ans
de Milo
voilà
c'est vite parce qu'elle a trouvé du
soutien et des conseils auprès de cette
association hyper super super au fil de
ses recherches elle a appris à mieux
comprendre son fils et adapter son
éducation
à l'heure du dîner par exemple il n'est
plus question de s'énerver pour qu'il
reste assis
ça sert à rien surtout si c'est pour
aller contre sa nature en effet c'est
moi je vais me fatiguer et puis lui il
va il va pas se sentir bien aussi toute
la journée il est déjà contenue en
classe si en plus à la maison je le
contient voilà c'est il va passer
s'épanouir en fait donc faut le laisser
le diagnostic du TDAH a beaucoup aidé
cette famille mais tous les enfants
n'ont pas la chance d'en avoir un aussi
jeune et ce n'est pas sans risque
pour le comprendre direction cette
antenne du CHU de Nantes ou Aimar
rendez-vous aujourd'hui
c'est lors d'un jour comme celui-ci que
son téléah a été diagnostiqué elles s'en
souvient très bien car c'était il y a
moins de 5 ans
comment allez-vous bien
un trouble on trie pas on sait comment
soigner mais on peut l'améliorer du
moins en comprenant ce qui se passe dans
comprendre donc ça avance quand même
beaucoup mieux oui j'étais hyper énervé
sur tout ce qui s'est passé et je
m'étais dit mais en fait ça se trouve si
je l'avais su beaucoup plus tôt j'aurais
pu réussir ma scolarité j'aurais pu ne
pas souffrir autant j'aurais pu ne pas
faire souffrir non plus mais mon
entourage car le TDAH n'a pas eu pour
seul conséquence son échec scolaire
pendant son adolescence son impulsivité
ses difficultés à gérer ses émotions
l'ont carrément mis en danger
ce qui se passait dans ma tête du coup
pour moi tout devait devenir physique
tout le temps des fois je m'en voulais
énormément de pas réussir dans ce que je
faisais ou simplement d'être moi-même et
du coup bah fallait que je me sente en
ville donc ça passait par je montais le
plus haut possible dans les grues dans
le rouler très très vite en moto ou
essayer de poser
plein de trucs comme ça qui
qui était totalement con les abus de
médicaments les abus de substances face
à ce type de dérive l'absence de
diagnostic précoce a été une perte de
chance pour Emma car ce traitement
médicamenteux qu'elle prend désormais
permet de prévenir ses risques en effet
d'après cette étude les patients traités
ont entre 31 et 35 % moins de risques
d'abuser d'alcool ou de stupéfiants que
lorsqu'ils ne prennent pas de
médicaments un effet protecteur qui
existe toujours deux ans après la
période de traitement depuis son
diagnostic emma a repris les études en
alternance ce qu'elle croyait impossible
il y a encore quelques années de quoi
rattraper le temps perdu
[Musique]
globalement quelles sont les
conséquences est-ce que souvent c'est
jeune sont en échec scolaire ça peut
amener à l'échec il faut un certain
temps donc les chèques scolaire c'est
vraiment la sortie du système sans aucun
diplôme mais en retard en tout cas des
difficultés
surtout en plus s'il y a d'autres
troubles d'apprentissage associés ou
d'autres difficultés psychologiques
le TDAH est lié aussi à des risques de
maltraitance parce que Ben un enfant
très agité et puis ses parents donc tous
ces tous ces risques s'accumulent et
tout à fait c'est ça la dynamique peut
devenir de plus en plus délétère vous
dites aux parents si vous avez le
moindre doute aller chez le médecin
quels sont les réponses des médecins je
vais chez le médecin vous le
diagnostiquez qu'est-ce que vous
apportez comme solution
donc la solution c'est de l'orienter
vers un bilan pédopsychiatrique qui va
souvent avoir recours à des bilans
neuropsychologiques pour bien mettre la
tristesse voilà
l'orthophoniste aussi pour repérer une
éventuelle dyslexie associée ou ce genre
de choses et ensuite
on va quand même assez rapidement
proposer aux parents une médication donc
des médicaments oui et là on attend sur
la Ritaline voilà faut parler de la
Ritaline avant d'en parler il se
médicament il a une histoire et une
histoire particulière je vous propose
qu'on s'y arrête avec cette infographie
[Musique]
voici Rita panison depuis quelques jours
elle observe que son jeu au tennis s'est
considérablement amélioré elle arrive
beaucoup mieux à se concentrer il faut
dire que depuis quelques jours son
chimiste de Marie Leandro palison test
sur elle sa nouvelle trouvaille un
médicament psychostimulant qui sera
bientôt commercialisé sous le nom de
Rita line quelques années plus tard des
scientifiques montrent l'efficacité de
ce médicament sur les symptômes
d'enfants TDAH mais comment au juste un
psychostimulant peut-il calmer un enfant
hyper actif la réponse se trouve ici au
niveau des Synaps ces interstices qui
séparent de neurones c'est ici que les
neurotransmetteurs comme la dopamine
sont libérés pour faire passer un signal
d'un neurone à l'autre dans le cas du
TDAH une grande partie de la dopamine
serait rapidement recaptée de sortes
qu'il n'en reste plus assez pour le
neurone suivant la communication entre
les neurones se fait moins bien l'enfant
a du mal à se concentrer et à se
contrôler le méthylphénidate principe
actif de la Ritaline permet de limiter
la perte de dopamine et de rétablir la
communication depuis lors la
prescription de psychostimulant pour
traiter les TDAH c'est largement
développé aux États-Unis près de 6% des
enfants de 11 ans sont sous traitement à
tel point que ces détracteurs surnomme
ce médicament pilule de l’obéissance
voire même qui dit Cook
en France les prescriptions ont
également augmenté en 2017 plus de 800
000 boîtes ont été vendues contre 26 000
en 1996
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qu'il faut penser de ce
médicament est-ce qu'il est
déconseillé est-ce qu'il est
systématiquement prescrit aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce que vous nous dites non alors
il n'est pas systématiquement prescrit
en les recommandations c'est la
prescription après échec d'une première
tentative de psychothérapie
dans la pratique souvent
même s'il y a pas eu de vrai
psychothérapie on va le proposer assez
rapidement parce que les parents sont
épuisés tout le monde est extrêmement
stressé et ce médicament est extrêmement
efficace il permet vraiment d'obtenir
une amélioration immédiate mais un quart
d'heure à agir donc ah oui immédiate ça
calme ça vous semble de bonne aloi de
faire très vite tout à fait plutôt que
d'attendre des mois le résultat d'une
psychothérapie qui doit se faire
néanmoins c'est important pourquoi la
psychothérapie et bien parce que la
guidance parentale est extrêmement
importante justement pour parler tout à
l'heure de ce cercle vicieux qui
s'instaure dans dans les familles
justement pour apprendre aux parents à
briser ces comportements qui qui s'auto
entretiennent avec leurs enfants pour
les déculpabiliser pour redonner
confiance aussi aux enfants qui
commencent à se dévaloriser parce que il
n'arrive pas à se donc finalement ils
sont toujours en échec il y a des gens
peut-être qui nous regardent qui disent
mais casse les pieds avec leur TDAH bon
sont des enfants tout le monde et de
plus en plus parce qu'il y a de plus en
plus d'écran parce qu'il y a de plus en
plus de sollicitations de plus en plus
de tuyaux tout ce que vous voulez défaut
dans le déficit d'attention
il est de plus en plus important alors
on a essayé de comprendre quand même
pour ceux qui ont des troubles est-ce
qu'on peut jouer sur la tension est-ce
qu'on peut travailler sa capacité à être
attentif Marianne Cazaux est allée
justement dans une classe qui applique
un programme on regarde
[Musique]
sois attentive concentre-toi fais
attention ces injonctions nous les avons
toutes déjà entendu comme ces élèves de
5e mais comment faire au juste pour se
concentrer pour prêter attention
faudrait-il apprendre cela aussi
cette professeur de français en est
convaincu il faut enseigner l'attention
aux élèves tout simplement parce que ils
ne savent pas ce que c'est
donc là demande aux élèves tout le temps
d'être attentif et on leur explique pas
vraiment pourquoi en réalité eux ce
qu'ils entendent dans taisez-vous etc
c'est finalement être attentif tout le
temps en permanence qui est impossible
donc finalement on se retrouve dans une
dans quelque chose qui est pas
satisfaisant et pour les enseignants et
pour les élèves parce que les
enseignants demandent quelque chose vous
allez l'appliquer avec cette chose est
impossible et finalement
on est insatisfait de chaque côté
premier exercice donc reconnaître la
tension
dès leur entrée en classe les élèves
cherchent à la capter en contact tous
ensemble en connexion
puis il faut leur expliquer pourquoi ils
doivent se concentrer pour combien de
temps et à quel point pour cela il
naissent remaki utilise une métaphore
si on tombe de sa poutre c'est plus
problématique que si elle est large et
basse c'est-à-dire que si un moment
c'est lancé dans qui donne une consigne
juste à l'oral et j'écoute pas bah là je
suis foutue alors que si je suis en
train de faire un exercice bon bah je
peux peut-être me déconcentrer deux
minutes c'est pas grave tout est j'ai
tous les éléments
comprendre ce qu'est être attentif et
pourquoi l'être est une chose mais
peut-on vraiment apprendre à mieux se
concentrer c'est là que la recherche en
neurosciences entre en jeu dans son
laboratoire de Lyon Jean-Philippe
lacheau étudie l'activité cérébrale de
personnes concentrées ou non
voilà à gauche un cerveau lors de la
lecture attentive d'un mot et à droite
lors d'une lecture distraite au bout
d'une demi seconde la différence est
flagrante
plus mémorisation qui s'active donc on
accède au sens en mémorise le mot
l'intègre dans une phrase et là pas du
tout un des éléments clés ça va être la
phase que j'ai montré de décision à qui
si tu à peu près par là
avec cette activité de la partie avant
du cerveau ou est stocker l'intention
qu'est-ce que je dois faire en général
dans la vie quotidienne face à des
tâches complexes et bien si vous avez
une intention très claire elle va
permettre de vous retrouver dans cette
type de situation là avec un tri très
facile est-ce que j'y vais j'y vais pas
je prends je prends pas donc la
meilleure façon de se retrouver dans
cette situation là c'est-à-dire de bien
maîtriser son attention sa concentration
c'est d'essayer d'évoluer tout le temps
avec des intentions les plus claires
possible
il est donc possible d'améliorer ses
capacités attentionnelles en adoptant
une telle stratégie retour dans cette
classe qui utilise le programme de
Jean-Philippe Lachaud manon a désormais
compris l'intérêt de diviser une tâche
complexe en plusieurs tâches simples
souvent quand on a plusieurs codes à
faire pour le découper et ça je savais
pas découper et du coup jusqu'à l'air à
tout le temps un peu à trouver comment
faire pour ce que je voulais tout le
temps répondre à toutes les questions en
même temps reste un problème de taille
les distractions or dans une classe
elles sont nombreuses très nombreuses
certaines apportent même une
satisfaction bien plus rapide que la
compréhension d'une leçon c'est alors le
circuit de la récompense qui prend le
contrôle de notre attention
c'est fini hein c'est parce
qu'effectivement ça va nous procurer
l'hormone du plaisir de la dopamine la
circular récompense c'est quand même à
l'origine de notre curiosité c'est ça
qui fait que on a l'envie on a du
plaisir à découvrir on a du plaisir à la
nouveauté donc c'est quand même assez
positif mais ça peut se retourner contre
nous quand on devient un peu un zombie
de ce plaisir immédiat
l'utilisation des smartphones et
tablettes peut mener à cette sur
sollicitation du circuit de la
récompense
d'après cet article de l'Université
d'Harvard chaque notification SMS ou
like est une source potentielle de
stimulus social positif qui lui-même
entraîne une libération de dopamine
c'est ce qui permet aux réseaux sociaux
de capter notre attention or selon cette
étude la moitié des adolescents de 11 à
14 ans passent plus de trois heures par
jour devant un écran
l'apprentissage de la tension et non
seulement possible mais il est aussi
urgent
[Musique]
bon dans le reportage il y a donc cette
exemple d'apprentissage ça vous semble
intéressant je pense que c'est très
important ce serait génial que ce soit
partout dans toutes les classes
absolument je pense aussi une question
je vous ai pas posée est-ce qu'il y a de
plus en plus d'enfants qui sont victimes
de ces troubles on estime la prévalence
autour de 5% et elle se restables donc
contrairement ça c'est aussi une idée
reçue il y a pas une déferlante voilà
maintenant on le diagnostic de mieux en
mieux donc on a l'impression de cette
augmentation dernière question quand
même est-ce que ces troubles
ils sont aussi créateurs de quelque
chose c'est ce qu'on pense et c'est ce
que moi je pense il y a une recherche de
la nouveauté
de l'exploration qui que j'ai pu mettre
en évidence dans dans certains articles
qui est assez caractéristique et qu'on
retrouve dans les études génétiques le
gène le plus fortement associé au TDAH
est aussi augmenter dans des populations
de migrants chez les personnes plus
créatives et tout ça donc il y a
vraiment quelque chose qui est encore à
décrire et définir précisément mais
c'est indéniable et c'est ce que vous
êtes en train de d'essayer de démontrer
par votre thèse merci infiniment d'avoir
été notre invité merci à vous merci à
tous de nous avoir suivi à bientôt pour
un prochain numéro d'état de santé
[Musique]
LCP Assemblée Nationale en partenariat
avec mgeen mutuelle santé prévoyance
vous a présenté état de santé
[Musique]